this culture that I'm speaking of
started roughly around 10,000 years ago
and it started with two major
occurrences the first one the
domestication of animals which
domestication of course is a very soft
and acceptable way of describing slavery
enslaving other beings of course the
second occurrence was intensive
agriculture which happened basically
after the domestication of animals and
sort of part and parcel with that as
part of that and what happened well what
happens to anybody when you enslave
another is a hardening you have to
harden your heart in order to do such a
horrible thing it involves confining
them it involves taking away their
freedom um it involves exploiting them
without any thought of how your action
might impact upon their happiness or
they'll their well-being it's very
selfish it's very self-centered it's all
about me um what is that animal going to
provide me and because that's first and
foremost in a person's mind then it's
easy to do exploitive things to another
being because you've convinced yourself
that you're benefiting and so
we have generation after generation
we've been brought up with this
conditioning that if it benefits human
beings then it's okay even if it's it
benefits human beings in the immediate
like right now immediate gratification
and so we see the repercussions of that
kind of mindset in our disposable
culture in our use of you know toxic
chemicals or nuclear power if it's going
to provide me with energy now who cares
about you know how it might impact upon
future generations or the the
environment or you know heaven forbid if
we even think about the birds or the
other various wildlife that might be
impacted by the nuclear power plant or
the fish or the other sea creatures that
live in the sea when we have to get rid
of our toxic nuclear waste or you know
this is just one example um and you we
see it played out in so so many ways I
mean okay we we eat we eat meat we drink
milk as a culture and we think this is
okay we don't even question it for the
most part I mean some of us are
questioning it now but it really just
began 10,000 years ago I feel that we're
at very ingenious species and that this
cultural conditioning is not really our
true nature that our true nature lies in
the joy and the happiness that is felt
when you feel yourself as connected to
the whole to all of life
in fact I think everyone really knows in
our hearts the secret to happiness for
ourselves and that we know that the best
way to uplift our own life is to do all
we can to uplift the lives of others
these kinds of ideas in patanjali yoga
sutra we find asana the word asana which
of course in our modern times
contemporary times many people think us
and all that means the physical exercise
part of yoga implying that that's
something separate from the spiritual
once again if you look into the word
itself asana it's a Sanskrit word and it
means seat seat and if you look into
that english word seat then you come to
know that a seat is a connection to the
earth so asuna really means your
relationship to the earth and of course
by earth we mean all of life all beings
and things this whole physical
manifestation so the practice in yoga
the practice of asana is really the
practice of perfecting your relationship
to all beings and things your
relationship to life itself and
Patanjali in the Yoga Sutras say says
about this asana practice as if you want
enlightenment meaning if you want yoga
yoga and enlightenment are synonymous
terms
and of course enlightenment means the
realization of the oneness of being we
don't have to think about how our
choices might impact upon the happiness
or well-being or future health of anyone
else but yoga teaches that the way to
our own happiness ultimately the way to
our enlightenment lies in how we are
able to enhance the lives of others